جنود اوكرانيون في دبابه تشالنجر 2
البريطانيه في قاعده عسكريه جنوبيه
انجلترا
هي اولى الدبابات الغربيه التي تعهد
حلفائهم بمنحهم اياها بعد عام من الحرب
الروسيه وهي مختلفه عن دبابات الحقبه
السوفيتيه التي اعتادوا عليها يا مدير نحن
هنا منذ اسبوعين تقريبا تدربنا على قياده
دبابه تشالنجر اثنان وصيانتها المدربون
جيدون جدا ويشرحون لنا كل شيء ولا عقبات
تحول بيننا وبين استخدامها
يتدربون هنا ضمن برنامج مكثف لاتقان
استخدامها ويريدون ادخالها في الخدمه في
اقرب وقت ممكن
يستمر هذا التدريب اسابيع عده هي حزمه
مكثفه من التدريبات مقارنه بالظروف
الطبيعيه لكن المتدربين الاوكرانيين لديهم
خبرات جيده ويتعلمون بسرعه حتى اننا
تجاوزنا نطاق ما اردنا تدريبهم عليه
دبابه تشالنجر اثنان التي تصل اوكرانيا
خلال اسابيع هي افضل دبابات القتاليه التي
تمتلكها القوات المسلحه البريطانيه وقد
استخدمت في العراق وكوسوفو والبوسنه
والهرسك يقول الجيش البريطاني ان درع هذه
الدبابه يوفر مستوى عاليا من الحمايه ولم
يسبق ان وقعت غنيمه لدى عدو في اي حرب
وزير الدفاع البريطاني شارك الجنود
الاوكرانيين تدريبهم وتعهد بمنحهم دبابات
اضافيه على المدى المتوسط ان اقتضت
متطلبات المعركه ذلك
لاعاده ملء مخازننا وارسال بعضها الى
اوكرانيا الاستدامه هي ما يهم الان وعلينا
تحفيز سلاسل التوريد فلدينا هناك روسيا
الاكثر عدوانيه وخطوره على اطراف اوروبا
نحو 40 الف جنديا اوكراني سيتلقون تدريبات
في المملكه المتحده خلال العام الجاري حسب
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه وهذا ليس سوى
واحد من اوجه الدعم التي تقدمها بريطانيا
لاوكرانيا محمد المدهون الجزيره من دورست
جنوبيه انجلترا